- This is worse than two girls one cup.
- [Voiceover] It's sexual,
but it's also about bugs.
- This is sex bugs.
- Ugh.
- Two dimensional air hockey.
(gargling)
- I don't know how I feel about that.
- My eyes are watering.
(gargling)
- Ew, also think about all the bacteria
that's in their mouth.
- Oh!
(laughing)
- I'm sweating, I'm sweating
that made me so upset.
- [Voiceover] So we're
going to play a great game.
It's called "Is This Chocolate?".
- Or what? Is it chocolate or what?
Oh, no it's a clothes hanger.
You look like an idiot.
- I tend to play this
game with everything.
I just put things in my mouth.
I'm like, I wish this was chocolate.
- Congratulations, you lost.
- [Voiceover] What?
- He's trying to sing a song
while getting a hand job.
- He's not trying to sing a
song at all. He's not trying.
- No, he's enjoying his hand job.
- I think they better have the version
where guys eat girls out
while we sing (bleep) karaoke
or this is bull (bleep).
- This isn't, they can't broadcast this.
- What I want to know is
what's going on with the woman.
- What do you mean, like,
is she getting paid?
- Oh, she's getting paid.
She's getting paid handily.
- Good lord.
- She's like this, she's like...
- And he's just like, uh.
- Either you don't cum,
and I assume you get money
or you do cum and you got a free HJ
while trying to sing.
- That's true.
- It's really hard to
sing in front of a crowd.
It's like, oh, it would be even harder
if somebody was stroking your dick.
- I respect the show, but I
also find it very disturbing.
- I feel like if I were to pitch this,
what would happen is that
everyone would be so,
both offended and terrified
that no one would say no to me.
- The Japanese gave us great things.
They gave us, like, fuel
efficient cars. Nintendo.
- Doesn't seem like they
have the same things
that are legal and illegal on TV there.
- I think America might be a better place
if our game shows were like this.
- Yeah.
- I feel like that is the core issue
of what's going wrong with politics,
with society and the economy.
- Yeah, it would definitely
loosen people up a little bit.